democrats in the media ramping up calls
to ban guns after the massacre in
highland park vice president harris
leading the charge while visiting the
area by calling for an assault weapons
ban
but it wouldn't be a calmly speech
without some of her signature word
linguine we'll deal with what we need to
deal with in terms of also as we move
forward
all agreeing that we've got to be
smarter as a country in terms of
who has access to what
and in particular assault weapons
and
we got to take this stuff seriously as
seriously as you are because you have
been forced to have to take it seriously
congress needs to have the courage to
act and renew the assault weapons ban
the media is blaming the violence on the
constitution because you know it's
actually racist
this is 100 us and it's because we are
essentially slaves to a document that
was written you know more than 230 years
ago by a tiny group of white
slave-owning men
you know and and we cannot break out of
the you know the bondage that we have
imposed on ourselves from feeling like
we we have to everything by our supreme
court has decided in reference to this
ancient document which is just not
serving us well
tiny
way to be sizes
and as the media focuses solely on one
act of violence they're ignoring other
crime over 200 people were shot and
killed over the july 4th holiday weekend
in cities
jessica this is now i believe the third
or fourth crisis that they've sent the
vice president to is is it clear to you
as it is clear to me that this is kind
of a performative political virtue
signal send her there she doesn't break
anything she comes back because she
hasn't really solved a single problem
well it's a different a communication
job versus solving what's going on at
the border or
the root causes issue are very different
things and i actually thought she did a
good job talking about the road decision
i think it is important when you have
the first female vice president to send
her out there to talk about a decision
um that affects women all across the
country and
word linguine or whatever we're calling
it i
i wasn't that caught up in it i was
caught up in the substance of it which
is that
renewing the assault weapons ban which
brought down death there were 53 less
deaths
mass shootings down by 43 over that
10-year period and then we saw a 243
spike in the 10 years after it
is a good idea and it jb pritzker to
your point um sandra he really captured
the mood and how people are feeling
about this that they want more and i
understand there is an assault weapons
ban in illinois but a federal one to
make sure that we don't wake up on any
given day on whether it's fourth of july
another holiday or just your average
tuesday and see more people needlessly
slaughtered with weapons that there's no
good reason that they should have access
to and i know that this kid in
particular i cannot believe that his
father signed off on this to help him
get it and obviously there were red
flags all over the place but we can stop
some of these shootings by making this a
federal policy again and there were red
flag laws that clearly didn't work right
yeah i mean
i was going to ask the judge about this
about there were so many red flags what
happened here who dropped the ball you
know i thought it was interesting
yesterday
with a press conference where i think
it's the deputy sheriff said well you
know there's nothing we could have done
uh because we didn't have anyone to sign
a complaint i and about 50 prosecutors i
know would disagree with that if you go
into a home and there are
knives and one sword and one dagger uh
and the individual had tried to kill
himself a few months earlier you don't
take the knives and then say gee you
know what we're going to leave him here
we already know he's suicidal he may
have been homicidal with all the not
these knives
they didn't give the information to the
state police
and then when he tried to commit suicide
and they say that they did give the
information of the knives to the state
police they could have prosecuted that
kid early on or they could have gotten
him the mental health that he needed his
father is culpable his father said um
you know he sponsored him in order for
him to get a gun in order for him to
sign off for that kid to buy a gun under
the age of 21 he had to answer questions
about this kid's mental health and
everyone knew about this you're living
with the kid he tried to commit suicide
he's a loner he's isolated you know the
kind of music he's singing you know the
crazy stuff that he's that he's drawing
and that's without even looking at his
social media so i think the parents are
in deep uh legal uh trouble as well they
should be and i think that the police
have to stop saying oh there's nothing
we could have done we didn't have anyone
to sign a complaint baloney i would have
filed a charge in that case in a second
in domestic violence cases family
members don't like to file a complaint
you bring the case in the name of the
people of the state of illinois and
wherever it falls out in the end that's
where it ends up but in the meantime you
get the kid in this system you get a
record on him and you track him from
that point you know sandra every time
every one of these cases and we and they
just keep coming uh always they always
turn out to sound the same but then you
look into it and there's always one key
characteristic that defines why this
might have happened and the judges uh
brings up the father signing this
warrant signing
yeah i mean
that is like what that is what led to
this how could he not be charged that
goes to the questions the red [ __ ] laws
and at the federal level obviously
there's a lot of discussion in the gun
debate over the red flag laws they
failed in this case so local police
never let the state police know that
this happened he wasn't just suicidal
when they found those weapons that were
not guns in the home at the time it was
knives and other things
he actually did say in the kill he
threatened to kill everyone in his
family that is in the local police
reports that was brought to the
attention of local police without that
being reported the state police as
judges pointing out they can't do
anything to stop that foid card from
getting in the hands of somebody who
clearly had intent to kill
i just have one thing when it comes to
kamala harris and jessica to your point
about this is you know you were talking
about abortion and the focus on that and
something that every woman in this
country cares about every woman in this
country also cares about their safety
and you look at what is happening around
this country right now and it is
terrifying where is kamala harris in the
city of chicago 68 people shot over the
fourth of july weekend 10 people killed
new york city 21 shot three killed i
just got an update on my phone a second
ago in the last 24 hours since the
holiday weekend ended in new york city
nine more shot two killed in the city
why not stand here and promise to do
more promise to end the vilification of
the police promise to amp up safety in
our streets because that you can make
the case is going to be one of the
biggest election issues come november
100
i agree with the judge i want the
parents arrested and the father came
back to the cops and said those were my
knives daggers and swords actually and
he got them back it's negligence he's an
accessory it's like aiding and abetting
the enemy he's housing and sheltering
and feeding a domestic terrorist so
that'll wake parents up if you hit a
parent like with a charge like that we
had a case on the factor where this sex
offender kidnapped a young child
repeatedly raped her in a trailer the
size of this table there was three other
adults in that trailer for five days
while this poor girl is being brutally
assaulted and the d.a didn't charge
these disgusting people with an
accessory
you have to be able to charge these
people because you don't not know what's
going on he doesn't live in a mansion
you go oh let's wander over to the son's
wing and knock on his door i mean these
are small homes you know what's going on
and in terms of the joy reid situation
the day after july 4th you invite on a
professor to slander the founders and
and besmirch
the constitution you got
a little advice for joy
last night i had a mermaid on the show
you did she had a fin
she was hitting from a babbling brook
and she spoke murmish
now people would rather see that than a
snobby professor so i suggest maybe book
someone like that instead of you know
what i love that you're coming out
you're pro mermaid i am yeah there's not
enough representation in cable news does
that surprise you no it's more
open-minded than you think yeah it's
amazing
you know what i'm gonna have to start
rethinking my own prejudices about
the magical creatures from the sea
that'll take a while yes it will hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now